huge cultural news on this most sacred
liberal Festival of national coming out
day
64 year old pop singer Madonna has come
out as gay
here she is on Tick Tock says if I miss
I'm gay and she throws her underwear and
it misses and then she kind of throws
her hand in the air
to say that she is gay incredible news
that Madonna is finally accepting her
true self
her most authentic identity is gay we
just didn't know all this time but
that's her true self
incredibly it is incredible because
Madonna has famously dated lots and lots
of men
Tony Ward Sean Penn Lenny Kravitz Tupac
Dennis Rodman Carlos Leon David Blaine
Vanilla Ice Guy Ritchie A-Rod Brahman
zaibot Timor stefans ala Malek Williams
those are just the first ones that pop
up on Google in the first result on
Google okay
she's been married twice both times to
men obviously and I don't mean to
broadcast the lady's Secrets but they're
not secrets this has been her brand for
over 40 years
if Madonna is a lesbian this would
appear to be a rather recent turn of
events
but the LGBT activists tell us or at
least they used to tell us until very
recently that sexual orientation is
something that you're born with that
it's completely unchangeable that's why
we have to ban the so-called conversion
therapy
until the last few years
when not only sexual orientation but sex
itself became something that changes
constantly and however it changes
whenever it changes
that is your true authentic self until
tomorrow when it will probably change
again and then no one can ever bring up
all the stuff that you said and did the
person that you were just yesterday
National Coming Out day is the perfect
holiday for a culture devoted to erasing
its past to denying its Traditions to
maligning everything that happened
before this very moment a culture that
insists upon questioning every ancient
truth and bans you from questioning
anything that happens to be in fashion
among the ruling Elite right now I'm
Michael knowlesis the Michael Knowles
show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show I'm going to
come out as a lesbian too many many
years now people have noted the
similarities the resemblance between me
and Rachel Maddow so let's do its
National Coming Out day I am officially
a lesbian I don't think this will affect
my marriage my relationship with my wife
uh my orientation will remain the same
but from now on in honor of national
coming out day to get a little bit more
attention just like Madonna is obviously
crying out for I Michael Knowles am a
lesbian my favorite comment yesterday is
from Dave M who says a friend of mine
had a 37 year old co-worker who did not
return to work after his third coveted
shot three days later they found him
dead in his apartment heart failure
terrible story
many such cases I have a relative who is
very liberal and was like all the
Liberals was coveted crazy and everyone
has to get a thousand shots and
everything and she said you know Michael
kovitz really scary
because my friend's father died
about two weeks after getting the shot
and I said oh are you
so you acknowledge that there are risks
to the shot that the shot is causing
heart problems and killing people
she said oh no Michael you're crazy what
a crazy conspiracy theorist I just mean
he had these heart problems because he
had had covid months prior
no no the shot that he had a couple
weeks before or maybe it was even one
week before no that has nothing to do
with it no it's obviously the kova that
he had six months prior that's what
killed him that's why you need to get
the shot people seriously think this
that's what the whole culture told us to
do
and then you have these sad stories like
you're describing many many such cases
we got to protect ourselves got to
protect our homes that's why you got to
get rain right now head on over to
ring.com
Knowles I know what you're thinking ring
ring is the video doorbell company right
yes they are and you can see and speak
to whoever is at your doorstep whether
you're in the home at the office or on
the other side of the world but did you
know ring also has an alarm ring alarm
is an award-winning home security system
with available professional monitoring
when you subscribe best of all you can
easily install it yourself even I can do
it but ring did not stop there ring
change the home security game with ring
alarm Pro which is why I have teamed up
with ring I completely trust these guys
I absolutely recommend that you go pro
be a pro just like me with ring alarm
Pro you will protect not just your
physical home but your digital home too
not just the walls and the windows and
the doors but also your data with an
Eero Wi-Fi router absolutely important
stuff so head on over right now GoPro
get ring alarm Pro go to ring.com
Knowles that is ring.com slash Knowles
National Coming Out day is not the only
sacred liberal Feast that we're
celebrating this week I should have
spoken more about this yesterday I
forgot it's it's now it's the most
important it's the most important
liberal sacred holiday of October 12
2022. that of course would be
indigenous people's day
yes no that was it was I'm sorry it was
October 10th today is the 11th National
Coming Out day tomorrow I don't know
what's tomorrow going to be transgender
awareness day but yesterday was
indigenous people's day
also known as Columbus Day Columbus Day
is a real holiday that we have
celebrated off and on since 1891 1892
uh but it certainly since the 1930s
we've celebrated it very regularly until
a bunch of liberals decided that the hey
Christopher Columbus because he
discovered America and he brought
Christianity and western civilization to
the new world and they've decided this
is very very bad even as they sip their
Starbucks lattes and type on their
iPhones and enjoy all the Privileges of
being an American they pretend that they
would rather live under the Aztec empire
having their hearts ripped out by
Maniacs on top of a pyramid so that
that's what they tell us and it's not
just the Fringe people telling us this
that's what Kamala Harris tells us
the vice president tweeted out yesterday
on indigenous people's day we pay
respect to tribal Nations and Indigenous
history today and every day let us
continue to celebrate and uplift the
rich contributions of indigenous peoples
their leadership has made our country
stronger
now of course this doesn't really make a
whole lot of sense because we are told
on the one hand the indigenous peoples
are so important they've made our
country stronger or there's such an
important part of our country also we're
really really evil because we killed all
the indigenous peoples so which is it do
they still exist and they make our
country stronger did we kill all of them
and that's why we're so bad who are the
indigenous peoples that we're talking
about is when I think about the arrival
of Columbus 1492 Columbus hailed the
ocean blue he arrived and it's true that
this experience of what of colonialism
uh had some problems with it there's no
question about that although it's worth
correcting the historical record most of
the things that people accuse
Christopher Columbus of having done he
just didn't do it was other people it
was other Spaniards in fact Christopher
Columbus very often was taking the side
of the Native Americans against some of
the more aggressive and violent of the
Spanish conquistadors and explorers the
the original crew not not the later
cruise but the original crew that came
with Columbus and actually a lot of the
crimes that he was accused of
he was accused of them by Francisco de
bobadilla who was his political rival
and who took over his spot as governor
of the West Indies so yes it's it's
true that there is essentially one
document that says that Columbus did all
these terrible things but it was written
by his chief political rival that would
be like trusting an account of Donald
Trump's life written by Joe Biden I just
wouldn't make a whole lot of sense
and uh and in fact he was he he was the
victim of a whole lot of calumny but
forget about that let's say that
Columbus did every single thing that
they said that he did
all of the crimes that Columbus is
accused of in his entire life
do not equal the horrors and crimes of
one four day period in 1487 at the
consecration of Tenochtitlan when the
Aztecs ritualistically slaughtered an
estimated 84 000 people
young people women ripped their still
beating hearts out of their chests and
kicked their bodies down the side of the
Temple
this four day period and it wasn't just
the Aztecs yes the Aztecs were
particularly nasty and yes when the
Aztec Empire was overthrown the
conquered peoples who were frequently
sacrificed by the Aztecs celebrated of
course they would have but it wasn't
just them it was the carab Islanders the
carob Islanders who who gave us the word
cannibal
the word cannibal in our language comes
from the carobs because they were
cannibals and they did all sorts of
crazy things and when Christopher
Columbus arrived in the new world he met
this nice group of Indians called the
tainos and some of them had marks on
their bodies
the marks were from the Caribs who were
complete Savages and it wasn't just the
carobs by the way going all the way up
into North America all the way up into
Upstate New York the Iroquois practiced
cannibalism
that so many of the Native American
tribes practiced cannibalism
Christopher Columbus for all his sins
the man never ate people okay
and so why do we celebrate indigenous
people's day if you're comparing
Christopher Columbus and the indigenous
peoples qua the indigenous peoples you
know them as a people Columbus was a
zillion times better than they were they
did crazy stuff they worshiped demons
and and slaughtered one another
constantly and then ate their bodies you
know the the Carib Islanders raised
babies to eat human babies and they
consider that a particularly tooths and
morsel according to the biography by
Samuel Elliott Morrison who's one of the
most respected historians in America
in American history
so no it's there's no comparison here
I I hate to put too fine a point on it
but Tony Soprano got this exactly right
his history teacher Mr Cushman is
teaching your son that if Columbus was
alive today he would go on trial for
crimes against humanity like milosevic
and you know Europe
your teacher said that it's not just my
teacher it's the truth it's in my
history book
so you'll finally read a book and it's
[ __ ] Tony
foreign
Columbus's shoes to see what he went
through
people thought the world was flat for
crying out loud
then he learned on another with a bunch
of naked Savages on it I mean that took
a lot of guts
you remember when we went to Florida the
Heat and those bugs well like it took us
to murder people and put them in Chains
he was a victim of his time who cares
it's what he did he discovered America's
what he did he was a brave Italian
explorer and in this house Christopher
Columbus is a hero end of story end of
story absolutely true but that's not the
end of the story for the Liberals now
Robert Reich who is that sort of
diminutive fellow who worked in the
Clinton Administration he goes on cable
news sometimes very left wing he said
get Columbus Day out of your vocabulary
today is now indigenous people's day
and why who cares it's just a holiday
right who cares the libs care the libs
care a lot they focus a lot of time and
energy and money on getting us all to
hate Christopher Columbus and take down
his statues and to celebrate the
indigenous peoples we're going to have
Aztec 10 octetland day or something why
because it is a sign of cultural
conquest and political Conquest
because it is a song Because human
beings need holidays and and liturgy
human beings need order to their lives
what we celebrate what we worship
defines our culture
and uh previously we were a confident
culture we celebrated the man who
brought Christianity to the new world
the man who wrote European civilization
to the new world the man who gave us our
traditional country
who started the chain of events that led
to our traditional country the libs hate
all of that and they've finally amassed
enough political power that they seem
pretty able to blot it out
you Google what day is it on October
10th this year you Google it it's going
to say indigenous people's day you talk
to the Democrat Party they're going to
say indigenous people's day you talk to
your teachers they're going to say
indigenous people's day they they have
conquered that holla it's a sign of a
conquest not of the Native Americans not
of the new world it's a conquest of you
and your country
the irony of all the anti-columbus
madness as we're told look Columbus was
terrible to the people that we would Now
call the Hispanic people
Christopher Columbus of course invented
the Hispanic people Hispanic people are
the combination of Spanish people and
Native Americans but you know the people
who who have this indigenous blood
ancestry in America they absolutely hate
Columbus and it's so offensive to
celebrate Columbus Day and that's why
we've got to celebrate indigenous
people's day here's a poll just came out
this is a poll from
WPA intelligence
it was on behalf of the Latino advocacy
group bienvenido surveyed a little under
1100 respondents and then asked how do
you view Christopher Columbus
the majority of the respondents view him
favorably
of course
this whole country named after him down
there
Colombia remember that country it's
named after Christopher it's not named
after the town in Ohio town in Ohio is
also named after Christopher Columbus so
the majority of Hispanics view Columbus
favorably about 54 53 only 24 percent
view him unfavorably so his net
favorables are 29 Points it's pretty
good
meanwhile the same bowling firm asked
Hispanics their view of Joe Biden
only 49 of Hispanics view Biden
positively 42 percent have a negative
view of him that gives him a net
favorable of seven points so Christopher
Columbus is much much more popular among
Hispanics than Joe Biden is but it gets
better because they interviewed uh they
asked them about their views on Kamala
Harris so uh only 45 percent say they
have a favorable view of Kamala Harris
41 view her unfavorably so that's a net
favorable of Four Points obviously
Christopher Columbus much much more
popular
so what does this tell this tell us
forget about Columbus for a second
forget about Hispanics
forget about Biden Harris
this tells us
that the cultural revolution that we are
seeing the canceling of historical
figures
and traditional objects of veneration
the reordering of our language of our
holidays of our Liturgical Calendar all
this craziness
is not the result
of a change in public opinion this is
not the organic bubbling up from the
people whose views are changing get on
board you old fogies the kids are
creating a new world it's not that at
all
this is being imposed top down from
Liberal Elites
liberal Elites who are pretending
they're they're pretending to be
offended on behalf of the Hispanic
people well we have to we can't
celebrate Christopher Columbus because
that would be so mean to Hispanics the
Hispanics like Christopher Columbus
they don't like you
actually and by you I'm sorry I don't
mean you The Listener I mean you Joe
Biden and Kamala Harris
the Hispanics are pretty clear they
don't like you guys that much they do
like Christopher Columbus so why are you
guys canceling Christopher Columbus on
behalf of the Hispanics who don't like
you
because it has nothing to do with the
people
it has everything to do with imposing
this from the top down
liberalism is not the voice of the
people and the the liberals who who are
always attacking the far right
conservatives and I'm talking about the
Liberals on the left and even the
squishy ones in the center and on the
center right
the ones who are a little afraid we well
we can't legislate morality we can't
impose our views on others we can't
we've got a little you know it's got
problems but liberalism you know it's
the best thing we've got at least a
classical kind of liberalism or just
liberalism you know it just gives people
freedom to voice their opinions it
doesn't
it doesn't that's what it pretends to do
but that is not what liberalism in
practice does liberalism like all
political movements
is the movement of a small motivated
political minority imposing its views on
other people
that's all that's almost always true in
politics and there's there's a silver
lining to that there's a bright side to
that which is that
sometimes conservatives get a little
discouraged we get we get pretty black
billed because we'll say well there just
aren't enough of us you look at the
polling numbers there just aren't enough
of us who support life who support our
traditional freedoms and civil liberties
who who support the the traditional
American Nation you know apple pie and
the truth justice in the American way
we're just we're not a majority anymore
so what
so what who cares
public Christianity is on the decline
Church attendance is on the decline yeah
okay so what
the Bolsheviks the majority of Russians
know that they were a distinct minority
a very very small minority of political
radicals
they had a great effect do you think the
leftists here in America were a majority
of America
by the time they reordered our culture
they're not a majority of America today
not even close
no we can do this stuff we can
defend everything we hold dear
from the the American Border to the
American Family to our communities to
our Second Amendment rights to our to
our religious protections all the way to
Christopher Columbus we can defend these
things
even if we don't have a majority of the
people or whatever you think the libs
have a majority of the people not even
close
we our views are much more popular than
their views are
trancing the kids and killing all the
babies and opening up the borders and
shipping our jobs overseas and fighting
Wars of Adventure in the middle of
nowhere for some abstract vision of
global liberalism so we can raise a
pride flag in Kandahar or whatever it's
just none of that stuff is popular at
all the conservative views are much much
more popular so why are we losing
because popularity is not all that
matters in politics it's not even the
most important thing that matters we
don't have the institutions we don't
have the power and most importantly we
don't have the guts to wield political
power on the rare occasions we get it
but don't tell please do not tell me
that all hope is lost because you know
only 45 percent of Americans support our
views that's ridiculous
just requires a little Clarity and
vision and courage without question
it is the liberal agenda is being posed
imposed by Elites from above nowhere is
this clearer
right now than in Ukraine specifically
on the on the expedition of the
president of the American Federation of
teachers
to Ukraine
yes Randy Weingarten who is this crooked
Union boss that that pulls a lot of
strings in the Democrat Party Randy
Weingarten for some reason is in Ukraine
she's there to in her words assess the
damage
after the Russian invasion and
bombardment of Ukraine
why why I so for so many people so much
of the Ukraine war does not make a lot
of sense
people are asking why are we involved in
Ukraine why are we sending all this
money to Ukraine why is this so seem so
important to so many of the kind of
Beltway type people but it doesn't seem
important to ordinary Americans and now
you look at this you say why the hell is
the teacher Union president in Ukraine
none of this makes sense
this doesn't make sense if you think
that America is a nation run like they
told you it's run in Schoolhouse Rock
You know I'm a bill up on Capitol Hill
and the bill the the funding bills
originate in the house and then they go
to the Senate and then they're signed by
the president and then that's how our
government works and if you want to make
some change in this world just call your
congressman
and that's it it's just laid out in the
Constitution that's not how the
government actually works
most of the laws the actual laws that
affect our actual lives in this country
are not passed by legislators that we
elect most of those laws are written by
unaccountable careers bureaucrats who
don't give a damn what happens in the
elections
and nowhere is this clearer than on
foreign policy since at least the end of
World War II
the American public has not had very
much to say about foreign policy a
little bit here a little bit there but
as a rule and anybody in Washington will
tell you this foreign policy is
essentially run by the Deep state
and there were some good Arguments for
this if the American foreign policy were
entirely contingent on elections that
happened in some cases every two years
then you would have no continuity you
would have Nations around the world not
being able to plan or trust in the
American foreign policy it would have
major institutions especially major
financial institutions corporations
not being able to plan ahead you you
certainly would not be able to have
the US dollar be the global Reserve
currency right you would not be because
the US dollar is the global Reserve
currency is predicated largely on the
fact that America is not a nation like
they say in Schoolhouse Rock America is
a global Empire we are the global
hegemon at least for now and so we run
the entire world and that's why the
whole rest of the world buys into the US
dollar and allows us to have the
one strong economy that we had
if you understand that America is not a
nation like you were taught in fifth
grade but America is a global liberal
Empire that is governed by a liberal
Elite managerial blob then it makes a
lot of sense
that Randy Weingarten would fly to
Ukraine because the war in Ukraine is a
war to protect the American Empire
at least that's our involvement in the
war the war from the perspective of
Russia which invaded is to expand the
Russian territory and to oppose the
expansion of NATO
it's a it's a the war in Ukraine is it
it actually is the only way that it
makes sense that we're involved in the
war in Ukraine obviously Russia is not
bombing New York yet Russia is not
bombing Los Angeles
but America views Kiev America views
Ukraine as part of its strategic
interest whether or not it is part of
America's strategic interest that that
is a question that remains open
but that is the argument at least and so
Randy Weingarten no she's not a
congressman she's not a U.S senator
she's not a governor or anything like
that she's actually more important than
really any of those people
because Randy Weingarten is the head of
one of the most powerful unions and that
Union has a lot of influence in the
liberal blob establishment and so Joe
Biden is going to pay a lot more
attention to Randy weingarten's opinion
than he is to some random Democrat
Congressman without question
he's going to pay a lot more attention
to the heads of certain woke liberal
corporations he's going to pay a lot
more attention to the heads in Academia
to the press to Silicon Valley those are
the people that wield power and they
don't just wheel power within our
borders we don't have borders anymore
they wield power over the entire
American liberal Empire
now the problem with managing this
liberal Empire is you get you get pulled
into all sorts of wars that you don't
necessarily want to be involved in
notably Ukraine which according to Joe
Biden is bringing us to the brink of
nuclear Armageddon those aren't my words
those are his words he mentioned this at
a fundraiser and so on ABC News the
anchor on ABC asks John Kirby who's the
Pentagon spokesman hey what about
Biden's crazy comments here on nuclear
Armageddon here's what the Pentagon says
joining me now is White House National
Security Council spokesman John Kirby
good morning John let's start with
President Biden's comments saying we are
facing the potential of a nuclear
Armageddon I know the White House has
said these are consistent with comments
he has used in the past but he's never
said anything quite as Stark as this so
is the president right are we facing a
potential nuclear Armageddon the
president was reflecting the very high
stakes that they're in in play right now
Martha when you have a modern nuclear
power and the leader of that modern
nuclear power willing to use
irresponsible rhetoric the way that Mr
Putin has several times in just the last
week or two as well as the the high
tensions in Ukraine uh over just the
course of the last few days so the
president I think was accurately
reflecting the fact that the stakes are
very high right now
so there's Kirby who I misspoke he's no
longer the Pentagon spokesman now he's
the National Security Council spokesman
he doubles down he says oh the president
called it a a risk of nuclear Armageddon
oh oh yeah that's what it is he's
accurately describing the stakes and the
risks
I tell you I know that Trump was a
really bad guy
Trump was such a bad guy he sent all
those really mean tweets about Mika
brzezinski's face he was just wasn't he
just awful I will say though we weren't
on the brink of nuclear Armageddon under
Trump
you know and so I think on balance
like I could
get mean tweets about Amika brzezinski's
face and
and no nuclear Armageddon or I could get
that wonderful return to normalcy with
good old Joe Biden who just wears his
aviators and licks ice cream cones and
falls off of bicycles but be ever closer
to the risk of nuclear Armageddon I
think I'm going to pick the orange guy
call me crazy I know I don't want to be
politically incorrect but of course that
would make sense right
but they're all doubling down because
it's true
as I've said from the beginning in
Ukraine Wars have started for a lot less
world wars have started for a lot less
than what we're seeing right now in the
first major war in Europe in 70 years
and so in response to this
are you seeing a an off-ramp are you
seeing a de-escalation
no Vladimir zielinski the president of
Ukraine is now calling on NATO to launch
preemptive strikes on Russia
is what should NATO do eliminate the
possibility of Russia using nuclear
weapons
but what is important I once again
appeal to the International Community as
I did before February
we need preemptive strikes so that
they'll know what will happen to them if
they use nukes and not the other way
around don't wait for Russia's nuclear
strikes and then say Oh since you did
this take that from us
reconsider the way you apply pressure
this is what NATO should do reconsider
the order in which it applies pressure
on Russia
I think I've had enough of this guy I
don't know about you I think that we
fought a cold war
for
what was it 60 years almost
a little bit less than that
50 years or so
without ever once getting into a direct
public confrontation with Russia
and we did that in in such a painstaking
way because we knew that there was such
a thing as mutually assured destruction
and we knew that's not a good idea to
get into a direct public shooting war
with a nuclear major power
and we did it and it was very very
difficult to do but it took a really
wise careful Statesman to and we got
very close to the brink sometimes
actually a lot of foreign policy
analysts are saying we are now as close
to to direct nuclear war as we have been
since the Cuban Missile Crisis which was
the closest we got in the Cold War but
thankfully there was an exit ramp there
and then this freaking guy is telling us
to launch direct strikes the whole thing
that we spent the entire Cold War
avoiding this guy Vladimir zielinski
says come on do it do it do it for what
for what I get it I get it that
zielinski wants to keep his country and
he wants to stay in power I get it that
it it's it is evil to to go in and
invade a country and bomb all sorts of I
get it war is a dirty rotten horrible
business and Ukraine's in a very
dangerous part of the world and that's
been true for a very long time I get it
people are comparing Vladimir zielinski
to Winston Churchill in a way he's
exactly like Winston Churchill not only
because he is demonstrating some courage
and standing up and defending his
country but because he's trying to drag
America into war that's that's why
that's what that's what makes him
Winston Churchill
but whereas the United States might have
some particular interest
in in a war that could dominate the
entire European continent do we really
think the same Stakes are at play here
in Ukraine
do we do we really do we really think
there's no off-ramp here what about when
Joe Biden said not that long ago that if
Russia just invades the eastern part of
Ukraine it won't be a big deal remember
that just a minor incursion
where was all this tough talk about the
territorial Integrity of Ukraine back
then
what about when Barack Obama said that
if if Putin wants to exhibit greater uh
strength and and Power in his
traditional sphere of influence that's
not a big problem what about them what
about on the more conservative side of
the aisle when you had people like I
don't know Henry Kissinger Daniel
Patrick Moynihan uh George Kennen all
saying maybe NATO should not expect and
forget those guys Pat Buchanan for that
matter that that NATO should not be
expanding
Eastward and should be a little more
careful about how they do it what about
those voices
huh
but no what are we hearing now I don't
blame zielinski for asking for more
Western support he's doing
what he thinks he has to do in the best
interests of his country so I don't
really blame him I do blame the liberal
blob that is completely destroying our
foreign policy
by indulging this kind of kind of stuff
it's completely insane
it was completely insane to dangle NATO
membership in front of Ukraine it was
completely insane to Daniel EU
membership in front of Ukraine
it is completely insane not to try to
find some kind of off-ramp here I was
speaking yesterday
with a member he's a a foreign policy
expert he worked for the CIA he was a
major Russia guy at the CIA he worked
for Vice President Dick Cheney he's
hopped around think tanks very serious
guy who pointed out look showing
American strength is a good thing but
the the way that we were able to avert
catastrophe in the Cuban Missile Crisis
was to show American military strength
Institute a blockade and all but name
but then also to do the behind the
scenes diplomacy to find an off-ramp
which they managed to do
are you seeing that anywhere here
I'm not seeing that anywhere
in in the U.S policy with regard to
Russia I'm only seeing the I'm seeing
the military escalation but I'm not
seeing any diplomatic off-ramp there's a
guy from the Atlantic Council Alex
pleats us
he works for the Pentagon he worked for
the intelligence Community now he's a
fellow at the Atlantic Council he posted
yesterday this long Thread about how
we've got to stop complicating this
matter of the war in Ukraine he says
after the time in Ukraine
that I've spent there I can confirm
Russia is running a strategic influence
campaign inside the United States
targeting GOP voters before the midterm
election in an attempt to undermine
support for Ukraine and cut off weapons
and support Russian propaganda is
spreading lies
their objective is to try and sway a new
Congress to cut off support Russia is
spreading false narratives about money
and weapons leaving the country on the
black market that isn't true if that was
happening they wouldn't be pushing the
Russians back into counter-offensive
Russia is also spreading nonsense about
Nazism in Ukraine of which I saw none
the ukrainians need what they've been
given and are asking for those who are
spreading any of those narratives
mentioned above are pushing Russian
propaganda and undermining National
Security okay what does he saying so
this guy this Atlantic Council fellow
is saying that the the Russians Putin is
targeting American conservatives with
propaganda to convince them to not want
to fund as much of the war in Ukraine
and that if the Republicans give in to
this and we we stop funding the war in
in Ukraine we're just going to be Putin
puppets and undermining National
Security
that's kind of a weird part at the end
right undermining National Security what
is the American national security
interest in Ukraine
there isn't one
there is an American International
interest in Ukraine there's an interest
to the American global Empire in Ukraine
perhaps but there is no American
National Security interest in Ukraine
whatsoever
Russia could conquer all of Ukraine
today it would not change American
National Security might be a very sad
thing might be terrible for the state of
the world might upset the world order
I'm not questioning that but National
Security is going to undermine because
of what
because you're going to see the Russians
start firing missiles from Kiev instead
of Moscow it's ridiculous but okay what
about his main argument
Putin
targeting the American conservatives
with his propaganda
saying that there is a Nazi problem in
Ukraine the nonsense about Nazism okay
let's take a look at some of how Putin
is targeting those conservatives with um
how about this article Ukraine's Nazi
problem is real even if Putin's
denotification claim isn't that's an
article from that right-wing Outlet NBC
News
is that where the Republicans get all
their news from those American
conservatives no you know where you know
where they probably get their news from
uh CNN is that that's probably it right
a far-right battalion has a key role in
Ukraine's resistance it's Neo-Nazi
history has been exploited by Putin
there it says the version of of
Republicans pounce for international
politics if Putin pounces he's
exploiting this but they're admitting
this is CNN is admitting not that long
ago after the war started March 30th it
says yes Ukraine has this Neo-Nazi issue
in the country okay that's that's how
Putin is pressuring
that's how he's using the media to
influence conservatives is by publishing
things in CNN that doesn't make a lot of
sense the nation how about the nation
Nation one of the most left-wing outlets
in the country neo-nazis on the far
right are on the march in Ukraine gosh
that Putin's propaganda machine needs to
get a little bit better targeting don't
you think if he really wants to
influence those Republicans with all
that nonsense about Nazism in Ukraine
salon.com even further left probably are
there really neo-nazis fighting for
Ukraine well yes but it's a long story
okay there we are also from salon and
then here's the fiesta resistance this
is my favorite one
Ukraine's Got a real problem with
far-right violence and no Russia Today
didn't write this headline
goes on to say
that
there are
Nazi groups such as the
c-14 group that have ties to neo-nazis
and promote National patriotic education
projects in the country they're
connected to the azov Battalion the
national militia and so where is this
article from oh this is from
the Atlantic Council this is coming from
the same think tank that this guy is a
fellow at this guy Alex pleatsas who
says that if you ever suggest that
Ukraine is a complicated place and you
maybe bring up the prospect of Nazism
having a role in in Ukraine that you're
pushing nonsense and Putin propaganda so
this guy's own think tank is pushing
Putin propaganda according to him
but of course it's preposterous
it's this the very same liberals who are
telling us now we can't raise any
questions about about the nature of the
war in Ukraine and what exactly the
American role should be in that war and
if we should really just keep pushing
for nuclear arm again and launch strikes
in Moscow for Ukraine the very same
people were the ones who were telling us
not that long ago that Ukraine's Got
This Nazi problem it's a terrible place
it's awful remember they they impeached
Trump for allegedly colluding with the
ukrainians with the ukrainians they said
but that was then
this is now and so from the beginning my
view on the war in Ukraine is the least
popular view it's that it's complicated
people think I'm too soft on
Putin people think I'm too soft on the
west people think I'm too I'm just
I just think
it's a complicated conflict and we
should approach that conflict with care
and caution and Nuance because as the
President of the United States says we
are on the verge of nuclear Armageddon
that's my view but we're not allowed to
have that view since at least the end of
World War II Americans are not really
permitted to have much say over American
foreign policy and part partly this is
for the good reason that if American
foreign policy changed every two years
certainly we couldn't have a global
Empire Nations wouldn't really trust us
we couldn't uh have our corporations
would not be able to plan ahead into the
future so there is I understand the
reasoning for why basically the liberal
establishment took foreign policy out of
the realm of self-government but we're
supposed to have a self-government right
we're supposed to have a republic we
should at least have some say over our
foreign policy right shouldn't we at
least be able to ask some questions
before the war in Ukraine broke out you
were not allowed to tweet support of
this group that is at issue here the
azov Battalion on Facebook that was
called promoting Nazi propaganda you
your posts would be taken down
then all of a sudden the war in Ukraine
starts and because Facebook is
supportive of the war in Ukraine and
because the liberal establishment's
supportive of it all of a sudden you are
allowed to post nice things about the
the Neo-Nazi group
and maybe there's a good reason for that
maybe they say well the invasion by
Russia is so in is so serious and such a
threat to the world war that we have to
but that's not my point
my point is that again and again the
left tells us hey everything we told you
yesterday yeah forget about that that's
not real
yesterday yesterday Oceania was at war
with Eurasia
no no we no it wasn't Oceania is at war
with East Asia Oceania has always been
at war with East Asia it's the same
issue with Madonna going lesbian it's
the same as you it's the same as you
with everything that the libs push us
it's the same issue with we talked about
this yesterday on the show
the Boston Children's Hospital says that
a baby in the womb knows that he's
transgender and that's why we need to
trans the kids day before that they were
saying that there's no such thing as a
baby in the womb it's a stupid blob of
cells it's not human it's not alive it's
not a person doesn't know anything it
can't know anything it's just it's
nothing
but that was then and this is now we're
not allowed to say what they told us
yesterday it's constantly changing
that's why they have to erase the past
there has to be an endless present
George Floyd's death literally set the
world on fire divided America and gave
rise to the activist group black lives
matter they raised 80 million dollars
through fundraising but no one ever
asked where the money went until now
tomorrow Wednesday October 12th Candace
Owens will reveal the truth in her new
documentary the greatest lie ever sold
exclusively on daily wire plus Candace
travels to Minneapolis to meet the
people who knew George Floyd and Derek
Chauvin and then follows the money to
find out just where it did and did not
go after more than two years of the
leftist media ignoring the story the
answers will shock and surprise you the
longer the media stays silent the louder
we get the more momentum we gain your
daily wire Plus Membership goes a long
way to ensuring folks like Candace and
Matt and everyone here has a megaphone
free speech is our greatest weapon
remember we are speaking for you and
fighting for your views and beliefs too
if you're not yet a member go to
dailywire.com Knowles to subscribe join
us today and watch this week as Candace
owens's new documentary drops the
greatest lie ever sold exclusively on
daily wire Plus
the
conclusion of all this foreign policy
talk is that for the past 70 or so years
Americans have not been allowed to have
much of a say over foreign policy the
foreign policy is just going to keep on
going on doesn't matter which party gets
elected it's going to basically be the
same foreign policy so who's running it
who's running the National Security
State
here's one of the people who's running
the National Security State just just to
make you feel extra super duper
confident this would be Joe Biden's
Secretary of the army Christine warmuth
who wants to assure you that the Army is
not woke
in terms of you know soldiers coming
from marginalized communities or you
know demographics that are not widely
represented in the Army that's part of
why we've got to emphasize positive
command climates and inclusion you know
we get criticized frankly sometimes for
being woke I'm not sure what woke means
I think woke means a lot of different
things to different people
um but first of all I would say if woke
means you know we are not focused on war
fighting we are not focused on Readiness
that doesn't reflect what I see at
installations all around the country or
overseas when I go and visit but I think
you know we do have a wide range of
soldiers in our army and we've got to
make them all feel included and that's
why a lot of our diversity equity and
inclusion programs are important
they're not woke they just have so many
diversity equity and inclusion programs
because of the marginalized people you
know who go into the army and they need
to feel included they need to feel
really really good about themselves you
know and their identities and especially
if they're a trans lesbian
zoroastrian it's really but we're not
woke we just we spend all of our time
focused on completely useless puffy
liberal nonsense and none of our time on
winning wars are coming up with a
sensible foreign policy which is why our
Global Empire is in complete collapse
that's it that was the subtext of what
she was saying
the very fact that this woman is the
secretary of the army shows you how woke
the Army is
no Secretary of the army should know
half the words she just said
no Secretary of the army should know
diversity equity and inclusion those
words should not be in the sector of the
Army's vocabulary do you know who I want
for the Secretary of the army I want I
want The Reincarnation of George Patton
I want every third word out of the mouth
of the secretary of the army to be an
expletive I want the Army to to bully
its members to the point of absolute
breakdown by the way this was this was
military training until about five
minutes ago you break people down
just so you can build them back up again
and toughen them up the only thing I
want the Army to talk about is
preparedness
I don't want to hear and she's not just
the problem I don't mean just a single
her out look at Mark Miller chairman of
the Joint Chiefs of Staff talking about
how the Army needs to waste its time
reading liberal books about white rage
I'm I am feeling white rage listening to
these people speak because these people
are are gutting American National
Security
not forget about gutting the traditional
American Nation they're not even if we
have a global Empire okay that is what
it is play the hand you're dealt but
they're screwing all that up too and
they're bringing us to the brink to
quote again the president of nuclear
Armageddon because of their liberal
delusions and Fantasies and stupid
priorities
insane
the the next Republican president
if we are permitted to have another
Republican president got to watch those
mail-in ballots but the next Republican
president next time we have any
political power in this country you
gotta fire this lady she's she's just a
career apparatchik for the Democrats
she's just a liberal bureaucrat
careerist got to get rid of her gotta
get rid of Millie
gotta get rid of all these people we
think it's a minor issue
we think oh who cares
so she said diversity equity and
inclusion it's not a big deal
it's a few training sessions okay it's a
few changes to our vocabulary
okay we're gonna have a transgender
bathroom okay we're going to change
Columbus Day to indigenous people stay
okay it's this minor change minor change
minor change although eventually your
whole culture is different
and it is changed not for the better
it's changed for the worse
speaking of the army no
there's one little silver lining here
which is the Biden Administration was
just asked to clarify
its uh stance on the draft
you know the libs are pushing to draft
women though that remains controversial
as of now the men have to
sign up for the draft but what about the
trans women
what about you know the men they're men
but then now they identify as women and
the Biden Administration insists that
they really are women and the Biden
Administration insists that these people
who are totally women really need to be
allowed to serve in the military
so okay but what about the draft
women are not drafted at the moment
do the men who identify as women have to
sign up for the draft
because the answer to that question is
going to tell us what they really
believe about transgenderism
and I am somewhat relieved to say
that the Biden Administration knows that
these people are not actually women
Administration says this is the new
guidance on requirements for Selective
Service U.S citizens are immigrants who
are born male and change to their gender
to female are still required to register
individuals who are born female and
change their gender to male are not
required to register
so there it is now you might say this is
hypocritical this is incoherent sure but
as rosh Foucault points out hypocrisy is
the tribute Vice pays to Virtue and the
Biden Administration is admitting here
for all their clap trap talk about the
transgender women are women and we need
all they all these hulking men in
leotards need to be able to swim on the
girls swim team and they need to be able
to use the bathroom in the locker rooms
with the girls and but for all that crap
when it comes down to it when it comes
down to brass tacks they they do know
that these men are not actually women
they know it
they're just deceiving everybody and
they're they're trying to even deceive
themselves I think also Biden is
realizing he's gone too far
he looks at the polls and yes the the
rule of the liberal establishment does
not rely
entirely or even largely on public
opinion but public opinion still plays
some role the opinion of the people
still has influence over the kind of
government that we're going to have at
least to some degree and I think Biden's
looking at it he says man we've gone way
too far
I'm very very unpopular I'm underwater
on every single issue and so now Biden
is really focusing in as we had we're
less than a month out from the midterm
elections
he's focusing in
two words
let me start off with two words
made in America
made in America
two words that's right
I'm gonna I've just got one word For You
Madonna is a lesbian I've just got three
words my name is Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Knowles show I've
got two words made in America everyone
is focusing in on Biden's senility and
his
inability to counter speak which is very
funny Biden gaps are always very very
funny
to me the more interesting thing about
this clip though
is what it seems to Signal about Biden's
political views
or at the very least of the political
views of the administration that wrote
that line
made in America
is this hold on is this the same Joe
Biden who said a rising China is great
for everybody is this the same Joe Biden
of the same Democratic party that's all
in favor of shipping our jobs overseas
and not protecting American
manufacturing and regularly mocking
actually
the people who've worked in American
manufacturing said well they just got to
learn to code
yeah those people whose jobs were
shipping overseas or shipping down to
Mexico
yeah they're just dumb idiots you know
they should have they should have gotten
a degree in coding or journalism they
should get a blue check mark on Twitter
they're dumb idiots you know forget
about made in America who cares make
everything overseas and then it'll be a
little bit cheaper and that'll somehow
even out that'll somehow
is that is that the same guy
because it sounds to me like when Joe
Biden says we've got a made in America
agenda
sounds like he's he's kind of channeling
the America first movement or the make
America great again movement it sounds
to me like he's kind of channeling
Donald Trump
Donald Trump is the first major
politician
certainly presidential candidate in many
years who put a focus on
bringing manufacturing back to America
in either party in either party
and that what's most interesting to me
about this clip
is the Joe Biden realizes if he wants to
be more popular going into the midterm
elections and going into
the General in 2024
he's got to be more like Trump
it's an admission and it's it's why I
tell you do not lose heart do not think
that all your views of your your
pro-life you're you support
marriage as it's been understood for all
of human history you you like your
borders and your American flag and your
apple pie and your hot dogs on the
fourth of July and that's you like
Christopher Columbus and you don't think
that 65 year old pop singers should just
become lesbians all of a sudden and you
know you're but your views they're
outdated no one shares your views you're
an old fogy you're an artifact they're
just waiting for you to die I'm just
telling you
your views are much more popular your
views are not dead the thing about the
tradition is that it's not some old
dusty dead thing from the past it's the
most vibrant thing that we have in the
present because it is endured so much
struggle so so many new fashions through
history and it is endured because it is
strong and your views are strong and
it's it's not just me telling you that
the president of the United States in
honest moments the Democratic party in
their honest moments they know that
you're right too and they know that
those views resonate as well stick by
them
the rest of the show is continuing now
you do not want to miss it okay I'm
bringing on the man that I'm playing
fantasy football this week that would be
Jake crane of crane and Company I made
the huge mistake of allowing my producer
Ben Davies to choose my fantasy football
team which is why I think I'm in dead
last right now so uh for some reason I'm
still making another bet on whether I'll
win this week I'm assuming I'll probably
lose this one last time I lost I had to
electrocute myself on camera who knows
what we'll do this time be sure to head
on over there the member block begins
right now
[Music]
foreign
[Music]